I love your coordination today what I am
here for your coordinator what I mean
who are these guys I like your shirt oh
this is amazing you know you keep
talking they'll they'll get over it
I know you're Canadian yes Yeah right
from BC from Nelson British Columbia
Canada no idea where that is
my man's tree hugger man so I understand
that you guys had a lot of fun on the
set of this film
there were pranks happening any truth to
this I'm glad our set has this like we
did great no you know we did do a lot of
pranks
Mike Doherty the director keep saying
him because I actually put rats in your
refrigerator I put a poop on your toilet
who put the snake in my toilet most
likely me what I was an infant child
Mike put when he sent me the poster for
Godzilla there was a fake cockroach in
the tube why didn't get poster for an
eyeball in the cherries both wow yeah we
shot on different days thank goodness
well we did not no not no nothis it not
the Hurricanes okay see what do you mean
every song adores their sir oh okay
we're having a good time yeah we
Godzilla versus Kong
my money's on Godzilla okay
I don't know yes I can't say I do know
I've just finished filming it in
Australia we filmed it half of it in
Hawaii half of in Australia it was so
much fun to film I have an amazing
co-star Julian Dennison and we had the
most fun a medicine really evolved into
a character that's you know undeniable
irresistible and super brave so this
this she really evolves into a woman in
the next movie which I'm super psyched
about so
but I can't say too much about the
Titans okay and then what about you if
you had to choose Godzilla versus Kong I
mean if I had to choose for the fight I
hate to say it but probably got psyllid
win but I just made I think he's a real
sweetie
I do it think he's a sweet boy that's
sweet
he is a sweet boy I think it's like
southern accent I know I know the
internet was talking a lot about they
want you in the Eternals with Angelina
Jolie desert tea to them did this happen
this was on Twitter apparently I'm in
space are you internet is too powerful
in Space Jam too okay I don't know what
that is neither to what animals are but
we've dried interesting C agency and
this single IV by really amazing acting
and I'm in it oh this could be me fully
confused on what the Internet has said
about me it's the second one had you in
the right direction but I heard you were
in the new M heard you Spock yeah no
there are currently no rumors about my
casting floating around oh great oh well
it was great
[Laughter]